let's go to our next caller from the
seven six zero area code caller from
seven six zero
who's this what's on your mind good
morning David and crew this is Tyler
calling from San Diego how are you today
good go ahead Tyler so David we spoke
about a month ago and I asked about the
general population not accepting the
outcome of the upcoming midterm
elections yeah
and I've done a little bit more thinking
about that and so I'm just concerned
with the state of society overall
like I'm having trouble visualizing or
understand how we're all somehow gonna
have this kumbaya let's be friends and
Americans a neighbor's again kind of
moment like I just don't see like I'm
concerned not about November 6 I'm
concerned about November 7th listen
there is not going to be a kumbaya
moment period in American politics
unless something extraordinarily drastic
changes and I almost hate to even
enumerate what those drastic things are
so like to give a kind of more not
outlandish example but at least one
that's a little bit more in the distance
maybe I have hypothesized that if
intelligent life is found elsewhere in
the universe that that would hopefully
have like a huge uniting influence on
American politics and even on
geopolitics relationships between
countries because once you realize that
we're not alone in the universe one of
the key questions of the existence of
life on Earth is are we alone in the
universe I would hope that once you
realize we're not alone in the universe
that all of a sudden the political
disagreements that we engage in on a day
to day basis would become very obviously
trivialized and we would realize what
the hell are we doing this is a real
problem that one is sort of it's it's
not super likely it's going to happen
soon unfortunately the other things that
I think would unite the United States
politically are also not good things
like for example if I I hesitate to even
say this and Pat is looking scared but
if the United States were to be bombed
or attacked militarily in a serious way
I believe that that would have a sea
uniting effect on the political spectrum
of the United States now would we solve
any problems or would we just create a
whole bunch of new ones in our response
to whoever attacks us which of course I
hope doesn't happen I don't know but I
feel like at this point the the
polarization is such Tyler that it would
take an unprecedent an unprecedented
event to kind of take down some of that
polarization sure and I absolutely agree
with that and that's kind of where I'm
looking at this from a 10,000 foot point
of view just even after you know a
decade in the army and having spent time
in failed States I really feel like
that's the direction we're unfortunately
headed here yeah thank you
Tyler thank you appreciate the call
great too great to hear from you did you
want to happen after 9/11 we were
perhaps most United as a country George
Bush had a 91 percent approval rating
was it that high if I was 84 Americans
seemed to get along well with one
another but the downside to that is that
we rushed into war we've had the wrong
contract and yeah it's not all fun and
games no it's not so that's actually
that's kind of a great example of
exactly exactly what I'm saying glad you
brought that up